another bad a bit of news for Fox News
that we learned yesterday is that
longtime host Greta Van Susteren is
leaving the channel after 14 years this
was announced yesterday who is replacing
her it's senior political analyst Brit
Hume the height of pomposity and
arrogance if I've ever seen it before
he's going to take over for Greta Greta
Van Susteren in the 7 p.m. our the her
show on the record that's going to start
immediately unclear what's going to
happen after the election no reasons
were given in the Fox News announcement
for Greta Van Susteren depart departure
she didn't initially respond to a direct
message looking for a comment but a
source that is familiar with the
situation said this was really a
financial disagreement that led to Greta
Van Susteren departure and Fox News's
Howard Kurtz reported that she was
trying to renegotiate her contract when
Roger Ailes left and that that did not
go well I believe there is more to this
and I'll tell you why number one when
the allegations first surfaced about
sexual harassment against Roger Ailes
Greta Van Susteren was one of the main
defenders and most public defenders of
Roger Ailes number two she had a clause
in her contract which said if Ailes
leaves for whatever reason I am allowed
to opt out so it's probably a
combination she defended the guy who
ended up leaving in total shame maybe
she defended it because she's friends
with him and doesn't want to work in a
Fox News that is Roger Ailes list that's
certainly a possibility but the other
element here is she said hey now that I
can leave because Ailes is gone I might
as well go in and ask for more money and
if they don't give it to me I'll just
leave I've been making plenty of money
here so I think that there is more to
this story
for sure Rachel and I know you're not a
big watcher of Greta Van Susteren at all
but it is interesting how when one thing
happens all of a sudden everything's
falling off the wall at Fox News yeah
it's definitely not a good day for Fox
News but at least they had the courtesy
to redirect her domain to the Fox News
website before she could get a hold of
it and then redirect it to adopting
puppies well so but she was able to do
that right
another she redirected her Greta
wire.com or something to some animal
rescue thing even though Fox News owns
the site have they successfully taken
back the redirection yes oh they have
okay well there you go
they they only they only lost out on
that web traffic for a few hours
real quick there's a media ID piece by
John Ziegler that makes an interesting
point and I'll put this quote up on the
screen for you to take a look at here
John Ziegler said the fact that the
highly regarded and well-respected Brit
Hume will be taking over Van Susteren
timeslot on Fox News is the perfect
example of the exception which proves
the rule of Cable News being badly
broken journalistically Hume is smart
sensible and cares about the truth
regardless of how it will make the fox
news audience feel thus his consistent
strong skepticism towards Donald Trump
throughout the campaign consequently he
has no shot in making it in prime-time
television
I don't know that I agree with this so
that this article is basically saying
Brit Hume is the backup guy right he's
he's more logical he doesn't have the
the he's not a blonde woman as is more
commonly the the people the the the
persona of the people that we see on Fox
News all the Greta Van Susteren not
exactly fitting into that and so he's a
guy who's the backup and we know he's
going to fail
I see Brit Hume as a boring pompous
elitist more than the smart and sensible
guy but he does at least up here more
rational on TV although that can kind of
hurt you on Fox News so upcoming megyn
kelly and Bill O'Reilly both have
contracts that expire next year at Fox
News we could be seeing a very very
significant shift in what is going on
there and you know many people whenever
we talk about Fox News they write to me
and they say David Fox News on a good
day any any particular show gets like
three million people to watch this is a
country of at this point I don't know if
it's 340 350 million people it's it's
over 320 million people that's for sure
does it even matter and the reason it
matters is that even though you're right
less than one percent of the American
population is ever watching Fox News at
any particular time they set the agenda
right wing influencers regular
we appear on fox news so it actually
does matter how strong fox news is and
the entire echo chamber is very very
strongly directed by what goes on on Fox
News when fox news started giving more
oxygen to the birther stuff about
President Obama many more people were
aware of it even though they weren't
getting the idea from Fox News because
you saw the echo chamber start to repeat
it so not the best news for Fox News we
will continue following it and of course
you can always send me your thoughts on
these stories on Twitter where I am on
at D Pakman Warby Parker is offering a
free five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed dot-com slash TDP s
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses hi which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker dot-com slash TDP s it costs
nothing